el ministro de interior y Justicia de
Venezuela Remigio Ceballos dijo que la
detención se produjo el día 20 de
diciembre en horas de la tarde en un
punto de control de la Policía Municipal
destacado este en el este de Caracas en
ese momento Gabriel Salinas te
trasladaba junto a otro individuo de
nombre Carlos Javier Gómez quien también
estaba solicitado en Venezuela Gabriel
Carlos Luis Salina había ya sido
detenido en Venezuela con anterioridad
por secuestro tenía expediente abierto
en esta rueda de prensa del ministro
ofreció dos videos en el que el
confesaba que participó en el asesinato
del fiscal paraguayo que era el quien
condujo la moto de agua en la que se
trasladó al homicida que propinó los
disparos y que había sido contratado él
se había ido en este año en 2022 a
Colombia ya había sido contratado para
un sicariato por el cual le pagaron ocho
mil dólares las las autoridades
venezolanas aprovecharon esta
oportunidad una vez más para cuestionar
al gobierno del expresidente Iván Duque
dijo el ministro de interior y Justicia
que esto era un ejemplo más de que Bajo
su gobierno se contrataban delincuentes
venezolanos para cometer sicariatos y
actividades delictivas en Colombia que
ahora había cooperación con las
autoridades colombianas luego de asumir
el presidente Petro El Poder y que por
eso podían Mostrar estos Resultados ya
el día de ayer el director de la Policía
Nacional de Colombia había dicho que
Gabriel Salinas no sería extraditado
sino procesado en Venezuela recordemos
que este es el texto detenido por este
caso que conmocionó a la región no solo
por tratarse del asesinato de un fiscal
que se ocupaba de casos de narcotráfico
y lavado de activos sino también por la
forma tan cruel en la que fue cometido
recordemos durante su luna de miel junto
a su esposo